انضم الينا الان من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري وليد نبدا لربما بما
اعلنته اذاعه اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
مقتل جنديين في نيران بنيران صديقه مره
اخرى تكرار هذه الاخطاء من قبل جيش
الاحتلال كيف يبدو وقعها وكيف يتم تناولها
في الاوساط
الاسرائيليه هذه نيران دبابه كما اوضحت
اذاعه الجيش وانه الحادث وقع الشهر الماضي
وكان هناك تبادل لاطلاق النار في البدايه
ثم قامت الدبابه بقصف المبنى الذي تواجدت
فيه قياده كتيبه للجيش الاسرائيلي في داخل
هذا المبنى في شمالي قطاع غزه فقتل جنديان
وتبين بعد ذلك بان النيران كانت صديقه
تكرار هذه الحوادث تشير من نظر
الاسرائيليين الى ان هناك حاله من الارباك
في صفوف القوات الاسرائيليه داخل قطاع غزه
لان هذا هذا الامر تكرر عده مرات خلال هذه
الحرب كان ابرزها عندما قتلوا ثلاثه من
الاسرى الاسرائيليين الذين نجحوا ولاذوا
بالفرار في منطقه الشجاعيه وقتلوهم
الثلاثه رغم انهم كانوا يرفعون رايه بيضاء
وقد خلعوا قمصانهم و سبق ان تحدثوا ايضا
عن اطلاق نيران وعن مقتل جنود في نيران
صديقه تتكرر بين الحين والاخر وهو ما يشير
الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي يقول بانه
قد سيطر على مناطق واسعه في شمالي قطاع
غزه لم ي لا يحكم على ذلك حتى الساعه وفي
بياناته وما يتسرب عنه من معلومات فانه
يواجه تحديدا في شمالي قطاع غزه ما وصفها
بحرب عصابات حيث ان هناك خلايا من مسلح
مقاوم او واحد او اثنين او ثلاثه على اكبر
تقدير يقومون بخوض معارك ونصب كمائن
ومهاجمه قواته وهو ما اوقع في صفوفهم جنود
قتلى وجرحى في منطقه شمال قطاع غزه
المحتله منذ عام منذ ال 26 من اكتوبر
الماضي يضاف الى هذا كله بان الجيش يقر
بان قواته تواجه قتالا ضاريا وما زال خاصه
في مناطق ايه منطقه خانيونس التي يقول
بانه قد عمق ووسع من عمليات فيها لكن
القتال ما يزال ضار ومنذ ايام اعلن عن انه
عززها باربعه كتائب جديده بينها كتيبه في
سلاح الهندسه ويقول ان قواته تقوم ب تخوض
قتالا ضاريا فوق الارض وتحت الارض يضاف
الى هذا ما كان عليه اخر يومين الوضع في
المناطق الوسطى من قطاع غزه او محافظه
الوسطى التي تضم مخيمات النصرات والمغازي
والبريج و
مدينه دير البلح ايضا وهي المنطقه الذي
كان يعتقد كثيرون بانها قد تكون الاكثر
امنا في قطاع غزه حيث كثف من قصفه برا
وجوا وبحرا في هذه المنطقه على نحو غير
مسبوق وعاد وقال بان طائراته استهدفت نحو
100 من الاهداف في هذه المناطق لكن القتال
الضار الاساسي يدور في منطقه خان يونس الى
ذلك كله الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي تدفقت عليه
الاسلحه الامريك
على نحو غير مسبوق لم يعهده من قبل حيث
كان قد كشفت المصادر الاسرائيليه ان نحو
200 و3 من طائرات النقل الشحن الجوي
الكبيره نقلت اليه اسلحه بالاضافه ل 30
سفينه منذ بدايه الحرب واضح بانه ما زال
يطالب الولايات المتحده بتزويده بالمزيد
من الاسلحه اسلحه والذخائر واخرها ما
كشفته صحيفه يدعوت احرونوت عن ان الاداره
الامريك ما زالت تتحفظ او تتمنع عن تزويده
بطائرات الاباتشي المروحيات المقاتله
والتي يطالب بها منذ اسابيع لان هذه
الطائرات يستخدمها في هجماته في قطاع غزه
وفي الضف شمال الضفه الغربيه وايضا داخل
الاراضي اللبنانيه نشكرك من رام الله مدير
مكتب الجزيره وليد العمر